welcome everybody to today's meeting of
governance and audit
both those that are participating and
those who are watching from home
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting
then please contact democratic services
officer
on call who will attempt to assist you
today's officer on call
is nick hughes has changed and the
number to call is
577-208
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please
meet your microphone this minimizes
background noise
and will help everybody in listening to
the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
persistent
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate in the chat
to the right side of the screen and i
will then make a note and go back to you
once the person speaking is finished
then on the meeting environment to help
would everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones
are turned to silent and they're not
used
to make or receive phone calls whilst
the meeting
is in progress please also refrain from
checking emails or conducting other
business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions
for the duration of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members
of the public the meeting will also be
recorded
and will be subsequently broadcast on
the internet
i'll now do a roll for the attendance
please can i ask members of the
committee to confirm their present
in the meeting when i read out their
name i will ask
for the attendance of those councillors
who are participating
in order to speak under council
procedure rule 20.1
separately councillor campbell
councillor campbell
councillor dexter
councillor boyd good afternoon
i've got apologies for councillor
braidwood
councillor crittenden present chair
councillor curry here chair
councillor coop here chair
councillor ghana i'm here chair thank
you
councillor pat moore
here [ __ ]
councillor shrub here chair
council of towning i'm here
so councillor campbell and
councillor dexter not here can't
counsel dexter's on holiday right
leave those two off i haven't received
any requests for 20.1 speaking are there
any members
who would like to speak under 20.1
let's note
are there any declarations of interest
from anybody here no
i would now uh like to ask you to
approve the minutes of the meeting held
on the 22nd of july 2020
copy attached to the agenda pack please
can i have a proposer and a seconder
i'll propose a second
that's a proposal no
no objections i'll take these minutes as
approved
that's approved
we now move on to the quarterly risk
management report uh
i'll call upon chris blundell to
introduce the report please
thank you chair this is the standard
quarterly
risk review report that's presented to
the committee
committee members will note at section
4.2
where the main key corporate risks are
identified
that there are the five key risks are
the same and the score is the same with
no change from the last report that was
presented
there has been some change obviously the
underlying circumstances behind some of
the risks so i'll just give
a brief um overview of some of the risks
there has been some change
so firstly in terms of east kent housing
performance
stroke transition members will be aware
that on the 1st of october
a new in-house
housing service will go live at the
council and therefore
some of the risks that were inherent and
related to actual performance of
east kent housing will no longer cease
to exist however
there will be um a period of transition
as the new service beds in
and we'd expect um that risk to be
reported to the committee
over the next uh 12 12 months or so as
the service is established
limited resources um members also be
aware
of the report that was approved by
council
earlier this month where we identified
three million pounds worth of reserves
in order to address the funding
shortfall
uh for the current 2020-21
financial year over and above that
looking at the medium-term financial
plan there's obviously pressure on next
year's financial
position on the budget for 21 22 and
onwards
we'll be looking to address that there's
also
this is compounded by not just the
uncertainty around covid but
national political uncertainty brexit um
and all the uh implications that that
may or may not have for
our financial position um in terms of
brexit
itself this obviously is still a risk
for the
authority but with the transition period
um finishing up coming to it and in the
early new
uh early part of the next year this risk
will obviously
therefore at that point cease to become
a risk and will actually just be an
issue so there will be issues that the
council will need to
address but it won't be a risk anymore
because it will be
a an issue that will have materialized
or not
finally in terms of coronavirus
um i think it's it's um quite timely in
terms of the
uh announcements that were made
yesterday in terms of the changes
to restrictions that are going to be in
place that
demonstrates the nature of this risk
that we're dealing with quite you
usually with a risk there is a um an
incident that occurs and we put measures
in place
to control or mitigate the impact of
this with coronavirus
we're almost constantly having to review
and reset this risk because
it is such a changing and developing
picture
um there are plans in place to deal with
not just the outbreak itself but also
the recovery
from that in terms of um
in terms of ensuring both the economy
and local community can
operate in the way that the council
would wish it to i'm
happy to answer any questions on the
report that
committee members may have
do any members have any questions
mike garner question please
yeah all right thanks yeah thanks for
that chris
there's one one item i'd like to ask
about um
under political stewardship which is
uh 16. i mean it's i mean i understand
group c um no vote or control
on the council so um
but is that the only reason that that's
at such a high
high risk i i know you you mentioned
that there remain
ongoing issues that could have a
significant effect on the council
um are they related to that no overall
control
and if not what are they that you're
highlighting there
thank you council ghana if um if you
don't mind i'll defer this to to mr
willis
as um deputy chief executive he'll be a
better place to answer that question
i was hoping chris you're going to say
to estelle culligan but
i'll i'll have a go answering um i think
the wording it because
this one is the owner of this risk is
tim howes the monitoring officer
um quite rightly who's who's who would
know the most about political
stewardship
um but i believe the the sentence that
council of ghana refers
to there remain ongoing issues which
could have a significant effect on the
council
relates to wider governance issues not
just the fact of no overall control
i think there are many councils that
operate very effectively with no overall
control for many years so
that in itself is not a reason for
having a score of 16. and the score of
16 of course reflects
that it's near certain to happen for our
four and
the impact would be substantial to the
council if it were to manifest
as an issue
okay okay just one following yeah
on that if you if if if it was just
relating to the no overall control and
as you say
the um a lot of councils work very
effectively
with no overall control what sort of
score would that
would that um give so i'm just trying to
gauge
the um what the impact of these other
issues are having on the
the score that would be given there
chair if you
are okay with me answering i am yes it's
a non-answer i'm afraid councillor ghana
i i couldn't possibly guess what
component of the score would relate to
one aspect of political stewardship over
another aspect of political stewardship
i know that's not terribly helpful and
tim howes is on leave this week so he's
not been able to make this meeting but
perhaps
he could provide a fuller answer to you
subsequent to this meeting in writing
okay thank you very much all right
councillor towning would like to speak
thank you thank you simon um regarding
east kent housing obviously you say
there's
an exposure there for the council surely
you've actually
assessed that exposure by now uh and
sort of um circled it and sort of set it
to one side
with regards to our funding for the
future or not
i can have a go at this one chair as
well please do
um yes i'm i'm the director responsible
for housing so
um the service that's receiving east
kent housing when it comes
back to council control on first of
october and
yes indeed we are very aware of the
risks
associated with bringing east kent
housing in-house and
and this as as chris blundell
highlighted on his introduction
reflects the period of transition rather
than
once it's back under the council's
control and the risks will change
somewhat
i think the the higher risk associated
with this particular
um transition was because there
we didn't know what we didn't know
because the housing stock was being
managed by ace kent housing
we were paying them to do it for us and
so once we discovered
and have discovered a number of failings
some of which were directly related to
the reason that we're bringing it back
in house
we were aware of a huge amount of work
that needed to take place in order to
mitigate those risks
and they didn't just include those that
we all know about now around
health and safety issues um in relation
to
um the the homes of people of our
tenants but also related to weaknesses
in the financial affairs of
east kent housing and the information
technology information
communications technology systems
and we've so what we've been doing is
working very intensively
across the whole partnership with dover
and
canterbury and uh folkstone2 in order to
make sure that we have as
smooth a transition as possible to the
first of october
and that's involved a lot of money as
well as a lot of
people being involved in making that
happen and we're in dialogue also with
the regulator the housing regulator
because they have
they're cited on these problems from
when it was run based on east kent
housing
and we have a plan with them to deliver
that goes beyond the first of october
so we're very acutely aware of the risks
and been very much of the work that
we've been doing is very much
directly related to mitigating those
risks and as chris
highlighted once we've got control of
the management of the stock
the risks become slightly different in
that then it's a question of
no doubt there's going to be much higher
expectations as soon as the council has
control of the stock
to start improving the quality of the
service and so we're very mindful of
that
and we're in dialogue with tenants and
leaseholder representatives
to make sure that that's that's carried
out as smooth as possible
and we're resourcing the new team as
best we can given that there was a large
number of vacancies
with any skin housing resourcing the
team with new appointments
so that we're best equipped to try and
manage that new service when it comes
back in-house
let's just ask one one more question
please
uh obviously taking uh the uh taking
e-scan housing back in-house
is there any possibility of clawing back
some of that money
that has been abused or paid out without
work being done
and is it is there any possibility of
that
um i suppose we paid a management fee to
east kent housing
for the delivery of the management and
maintenance of our housing stock
and the reason why we're not going to do
that anymore is because we weren't happy
with the sort of service that we were
getting from east kent housing
that was fundamentally the reason why
cabinet agreed to bring it back in-house
but the answer to your question
counselor telling is no um
because we reckon at the end of east
kent housing's life which is now pretty
close
it won't have it will it will it won't
have more than two eight minutes to rub
together in the bank
it's almost completely exhausted indeed
one of the risks we've been managing
is to make sure east kent housing
doesn't trade whilst insolvent because
it's a company
and the the board of east kent housing
who are responsible legally for this
are the chief executives of the relevant
um
districts so our chief executive is on
the board of east kent housing
and the board is responsible for making
sure that the entity the company isn't
trading whilst insolvent
so we've been very mindful to make sure
that we didn't
screw every penny out of east kent
housing and force it into insolvency
because then that would have damaged
the services to the tenants and
leaseholders at a time when we wanted
a more managed transition
back to the council
thank you okay
would anybody else have any would like
to speak on this
item i don't have anybody up
all right recommendations to
to approve the review of corporate risks
please can i have a proposal and a
seconder
propose
i'll second it for you thank you
there are no objections i'll take these
as approved
thank you
we'll now move on to quarterly internal
audit update
i'll call on simon webb to introduce the
report please
thank you chair good afternoon members
this is our regular quarterly internal
audit update report summarizing the work
of the east cambodia partnership
on your behalf in the last quarter
on page 27 of the report there is a
table
summarizing the three audits which have
been finalized during this period
you'll see that we concluded reasonable
assurance in the areas
of member code of conduct and sanders
arrangements
and also payroll we were only able to
conclude no assurance in the area of
benefits in kind
which is largely administered on your
behalf by the east kent's
hr partnership the reasons for that
are detailed in the bullet points on
page 30.
there is also a management response
there from east kennedy hr
i am pleased to report that there are a
lot of easy wins there to get that up to
reasonable assurance
and i would expect that once we've
undertaken the follow-up review in that
area
those recommendations will have been
implemented and we will be able to
conclude at least reasonable assurance
follow-up is a very important part of
internal audit work
during the period under review we've
undertaken two follow-up reviews and
they are detailed on page 31
of the agenda pack
one was on uh psm compliance
and the other was the very important
area of tenant health and safety
in this instance it was lifts
now that was an area of considerable
concern
previously and formed part of the
referral to the regular housing
regulator
it was no assurance i'm pleased to
report that it has been
increased to reasonable assurance and
there is some detail at
3.3 in terms of the progress that has
been made
obviously timmy uh funny has more high
rise blocks than some of your neighbors
in east kent
and therefore um a positive move of
assurance as regards lifts
is an important move forward
um on page 32 at point 4.1 we detail
the work in progress which is currently
underway and
that gives a list of some of the audits
that you can expect to see coming
forward
to this committee in subsequent meetings
um on page 34 onwards
there is a table showing the progress
against the agreed
2021 plan obviously we had a bit of a
hiatus um
in april may and june um at the start of
the covid and pandemic
i've reported to the last meeting that
we were making good progress
um in terms of the delivery of the plan
and that does continue and we already
have a couple of
a couple more audits finalized which
we've been bringing forward to the
november meeting of this committee
um page 36 shows progress against the
east kent housing plan as well
which obviously will be uh brought into
the finale plan from the first of
october
uh page 36 and turning the page on to 37
also shows
the plan to escape services civica and
he's getting hr
so it shows the time that we've spent
thus far against the various reviews
on page 42 of the report
there is a table showing those areas
where we concluded either limited or no
assurance previously
um and where we are with the follow-ups
it's really just to bring
to keep that on the radar um to make
sure that we bring those forward to you
at subsequent meetings um one of the
most important on there you'll see
is fire safety um eastgate housing 10
health and safety uh that is a work in
progress um
but it is approaching draft report stage
and that will be reported to the next
meeting of this committee in november
um that is the final area of tenant
health and safety that we still need to
follow up
um and yeah good progress is being made
on that follow-up and that will be
reported at the next meeting
finally pages 43 and 44
show a balanced scorecard of performance
indicators for the east cambodia
partnership
itself it shows progress against the
plan
productivity and as well as a class
probably day
etc that's it from
me chair but obviously happy to take
questions on any of the items on the
agenda
all right well it appears we don't have
uh anybody at the moment in the chat box
requesting to speak
um i believe
sarah
is she online with us yes i am
you are oh uh would you be happy to
just update us on grant thornton's
position um
with regard to the we received from east
kent
partnership member um of the
sort of great concerns going forwards as
we
center spend a lot of time looking at
retrospective matters
um i'm keen not not to get tripped up in
the future
um yes thank you and apologies for uh
for joining a little bit late there to
this evening
um so in terms of and the reason that we
don't have a written paper to update you
is that we really are very much at the
early stages of our
audit um the financial statements audit
um we received the accounts at the end
of
or the beginning of this month and the
team are working with
tim chris and the wider finance team the
elements
that you're referring to in christine's
letter is something that we're looking
at as part of our value for money work
um and so we are uh
we're at a very early stage with that
um there are a number of issues that we
just want to
work through and understand uh the
position so we're not
we at this point we do not have anything
to update
to members um and whilst i can
appreciate that
being a little frustrating you can also
appreciate that you would want us to
have done um
our proper audit work before reaching a
conclusion as well
so it's certainly something that is in
in progress but not
not not complete thank you
um does anybody have any anybody else
have a question
or is on this item on the previous item
um councillor mike
garner thank you
yeah um could you do you have any idea
sort of how long it's going to be before
you're going to be able to report back
to us on
on those issues um
so the the current work program that
we're working with um
with with tim and chris is for us to be
able to give an opinion by the end of
uh oct november sorry so this will be a
work
going on over october and november and
we we would we'd hope to be able to give
our opinion on the financial statements
for that stage
the value for money um i believe there's
there's some
objections that are still in progress
from last year
that are drawing drawing to a conclusion
i spoke to my colleague who's dealing
with those
um earlier today um so i think we're
we're thinking towards the end of
november that we'd be able to report
back to you
but it will depend on the extent
of um extent of what we need to do
thank you it would be helpful if that
came in for our november
meeting as well i mean i think that's
that's our aim
um it will depend on the complexity of
uh of what our work involves okay
thank you very much
i believe i need a proposer and a
seconder for item five
i'll propose cedric thank you city i'll
second it councillor shrub
right i don't hear any objections
so
i'll take these as approved thank you
very much
that concludes uh the business for
tonight's meeting
i declare this meeting closed thanks to
everybody
for participating and uh for those
watching from home
the live stream for this meeting will
end now and thank you all
good night thank you